Speaker 1: I want to go through with you today
a few different clips of the extraordinarily
childish, humiliating and anti mask tantrums
that we're seeing around the country on yesterday's
show.
I had coverage of this anti vaccine mandate
rally in New York City, and it was crazy.
There are also now more and more school districts
as school has already started for the fall
in some places and is within a week or two
of starting and other places.
There are more and more places that are now
having hearing school board hearings of various
kinds.
And there are furious parents showing up and
saying, no masks for my kids.
Now, I'm not going to belabor this point,
but I've made it before and I've tweeted about
it.
And many of you seem to agree.
I'm imagining if I'm a nine year old in school
and I am told there are going to be mask requirements
in school.
But don't worry, little Johnny, I'm going
to go crazy demanding they not force you to
wear a mask.
I think that the wearing of the mask wouldn't
be that bad compared to knowing my mom is
going cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs on Zoome meetings
and at a school board meeting.
I think that that would be far worse for the
kid.
But at the end of the day, I am not a parent,
so I guess I can't say for sure, but that's
certainly my instinct.
Let's take a look at some examples.
Here is an A.M. at the Shenandoah Halwa.
I know that the word is probably it's the
root of it seems to be the same as Shenandoah,
but it's the different spelling.
I believe it's pronounced Shenandoah.
How Central School District meeting in New
York.
Maybe it is just pronounced Shenandoah, even
though it's spelled in a way I've not seen
before.
OK, in any case, here is some crazy scenario
where a parent says it's possible that the
masks will lead to sexual assault.
My guess is they say because you wouldn't
know who it is because they're wearing
Speaker 2: your son or daughter is about to
become that 10 percent statistic.
They're being led down the hallway by the
rapist.
They're walking casually around by passing
students and teachers along for the students.
And teachers are smiling at the sort of person
behind their mask.
But nobody can see the smile.
They disappear and your child is violently
raped.
What we do know is that the rapist had told
your child that if he or she said a word to
anyone as they were walking, they would tell
them.
What we do know is that your son or daughter
was smart enough to mouth the words, help
me.
Because they were being led away.
Speaker 1: Oh, I see.
And so if they're wearing a mask, they wouldn't
be able to mouth that.
Speaker 2: All the while we were smiling at
this victim behind her mask.
The victim was trying to communicate their
distress to us without the use of vocal words
which failed their son or daughter in those
moments.
And they were.
We could have stopped such a violent act from
occurring.
But our choice to be complicit,
Speaker 1: it's it's kind of like a weird
disaster porn.
I mean, that's an insanely specific scenario.
I don't I don't know really what to make of
it other than if you have to come up with
such crazy scenarios to justify why just the
kids shouldn't all wear masks to prevent the
spread, especially since they're mostly not
vaccinated yet.
You're probably reaching beyond what makes
sense is sort of my instinct.
Here's another one.
This is an anti massacre at Higley Unified
School District in Gilbert, Arizona.
The video is very dark.
I don't know why.
It's just the video we have.
And she says science is ridiculous.
Speaker 3: I can't figure out by now the science
is ridiculous.
Then you're probably driving around in your
car with a mask on by yourself.
And I can't help you at this point, nor do
I want to.
It's not my job.
I appreciate what you want to do for you and
your family.
I would appreciate it if you respected what
I did for me and my family, because that's
where we live.
The United States of America.
God bless America.
The end.
Thank you.
Speaker 1: And I am as disturbed by the applause
that this stuff gets as I am by the content
of it.
And just really funny thing, the woman sort
of has a look like Roseanne Barr and Roseanne
Barr, former former husband, Tom Arnold, who's
a supporter of The David Pakman Show.
The first response on Twitter is, I swear
Roseanne used to be funny, but this is this
is really, really bad.
Really, really bad.
And unfortunately, the amount of support it
gets is maybe the scariest the scariest part
altogether.
And then lastly here, here's an A.M. that
completely loses his mind at a meeting of
the Board of Commissioners in Ottawa County,
Michigan.
Let's listen to that.
Speaker 3: Dan Van der Swagged.
Speaker 1: Here comes down.
Speaker 4: That's my father in law right there
speaking on behalf of his grandkids.
Speaker 3: You were that deprived of your
face.
If he started right now, could you smell it?
That's how stupid this is.
We're all playing games here with people's
lives.
Speaker 1: Now, let me address that, because
there's this is a talking point that's been
spreading and it's spreading.
Not not intentionally using a pun.
This is a talking point that's been floating
around, which is is if you can smell something
through the mask as the as the gentleman here
astutely points out and decorously points
out, if you can smell a fart through the mask,
then it couldn't really be protecting you
from covid.
This is this is actually so simple.
The smell from a fart is caused by some version
of methane.
I think it's called like methane Theal or
something like that, and like sulfur containing
molecules.
The point is the the molecules that contain
the fart smell are really, really small.
They're way smaller than coronavirus.
Coronavirus droplets are up to thirty four
thousand percent larger than fart smell carrying
molecules.
So it's such a stupid topic, but at the same
time it keeps getting repeated.
If you can smell through the mask, clearly
it's doing nothing.
No, no, no.
Let's look at the size of the molecules.
And of course, the nit of the mask also makes
a difference.
Let's listen to a little more of this guy.
Speaker 3: I'm sick of it.
I would represent all these hardworking guys
that couldn't be here today to take off work,
to put up with this PSA you guys are putting
down.
And there's hell coming that's coming.
And I'm not going to threaten anybody, but
there's a lot of good guys out there ready
to do bad things soon.
Watch Mitch Coleman.
Speaker 1: Not him, he would never do that
stuff.
He's not threatening us, but he's just letting
us know other people might do stuff if they
have a
Speaker 3: mandate against a no no goals.
Speaker 1: Oh, now it's gone completely off
Speaker 4: states voluntarily informed consent.
Speaker 1: All right, I can't even I can't
even listen to any more of that.
So that's what's going on.
And if these people put five percent of the
energy into helping to end the pandemic that
they put into things that would help prolong
it, we might be out of it by now.
Let me know your thoughts.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Welcome back to the show, remember that our
primary source of funding is people who sign
up for memberships at Join Pakman Dotcom,
you'll get an extra show every day, as well
as commercial free audio and video feeds of
the show.
And it just feels good to do.
Go to join Pakman Dotcom and sign up today.
Let's hear from some folks in the audience.
We do this now via discord.
You can join up at David Pakman dotcom slash
discord.
The waiting lobby is where you go if you would
like to be put on the air.
Let's start today with Matt from Virginia,
Matt from Virginia.
You are on the air and would love to hear
from you.
Matt from Virginia, you are on the air.
Matt.
Hmm.
I guess no, Matt from Virginia,